dans chéri
tu ne sais pas si dramatique il a fallu
casser tout commence avec une gifle une
grosse gifle assénée à une cliente par
la mère d'hugo en plein centre du centre
commercial sans suite des ennuis
judiciaires et se pose la question est
ce que la mère parfaite existe pense que
les maires sont toujours imparfaite bon
je me oui la mienne est parfait
mais on demande tellement au mr on leur
demande tout faudrait qu'elle soit
parfaite parce que la merde c'est
toujours les maires ont toujours tort
ont tout faux c'est parce qu'on veut
tellement on attend tellement belle non
embrasser mère et son fils qui
entretiennent une relation si
fusionnelle que toxiques du coup le fils
rêve de devenir couturier et aspire la
beauté en toute chose
l'apprentissage qui à faire c'est de
mélanger de mélanger la souffrance d'al
hader qui fait partie de la beauté c'est
là que d'accepter cette part le du monde
possédait de tirer quelque chose de beau
de la souffrance qu'ont combinant la vie
plus de trente ans après le succès des
feuillus est qu'ils ont révélé après le
succès de la nuit ou laurier gaudreault
s'est réveillé michel marc bouchard est
de retour au tnm et continue d'explorer
le pouvoir réparateur de l'art
est ce que l'arbre celui que l'on créé
est ce que ce n'est pas une forme de
réconciliation avec la vie est ce que à
travers cela peut apporter une
rédemption est ce que l'art me permets
de pardonner je pense que ben je dirais
pas la fin de la pièce mais je pense que
quand par action mais autre pièce où je
laisse plutôt les choux gras de suspens
je crois que j'y réponds
thomas la ferme les muses orphelines
les grandes chaleurs michel marc
bouchard c'est plus de 25 pièces maintes
fois adapté au cinéma est présenté aux
quatre coins de la planète un michalak
d'abord c'est toucher le top québécois
et si on touche notre propre peuple on
peut toucher le monde entier et c'est
tout il vient nous attaquer aucun
embrasse et une pièce saisissante comme
une gifle qui célèbrent l'art il nous
invite à embrasser la vie dans toute sa
complexité
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal